lebenslänglich für den kitzbühel killer
am mittwoch wurde das urteil gegen
andreas de gesprochen
der 27 jährige hatte am 6 oktober 2009
10 seine ex freundin ihre eltern ihren
bruder sowie ihren neuen freund
kaltblütig erschossen
vor der richterin bekennt andreas er
sich für schuldig außer seinem schmerz
für die trennung konnte er kein
richtiges motiv für die bluttat nennen
er gab an einen tunnelblick gehabt zu
haben
nach 45 minuten beratungszeit kamen die
geschworenen zu dem urteil
der verurteilte bedauerte seine tat wenn
er könnte würde er die zeit zurückdrehen
nun muss er lebenslänglich hinter gitter
am abend vor der tat traf sich andreas
mit seiner ex energien in einer bar in
kitzbühel
es kam zum streit beide fuhren nach
hause gegen 4 uhr morgens wo er zu ihrem
haus ihr vater robert öffnete die tür
ließ ihn aber nicht herein
kurz darauf fuhr andreas er nach hause
um seine pistole zwei volle magazine und
einen baseballschläger zu holen
zurück beim haussender ex erschoss das
zuerst den vater dann ihren bruder ihre
mutter andrea und anschließend nadine
und ihren neuen freund florian insgesamt
16 patronen wurden am tatort gesichert
nach der tat ging er zur polizei in
kitzbühel legte die waffen auf den tisch
und sagte er habe soeben fünf menschen
ermordet
[Musik]